[Music]
standing for the anthem of the country
they've just become part of at least
according to Moscow the leaders of the
four Ukrainian regions appeared in red
square with President Vladimir Putin a
very public sign of loyalty hours after
a signing ceremony that saw them become
part of the Russian Federation
Russia held so-called referendums in the
four partially occupied areas of Ukraine
over the last week the votes denounced
by Western governments and the Ukrainian
government as a sham all delivered a
resounding yes to joining Russia
the choice of the people in the areas of
Donetsk luhansk zaparitzia and Hassan is
not up for discussion it's been made
Russia will not betray it
[Applause]
and the authorities in Kiev today should
treat that Free Will of the people with
respect and no other way
that's the only path to peace we will
defend our land using all forces and
means at our disposal and we'll do
everything we can to protect the
security of our people in total Russia's
illegally annexed about 15 percent of
Ukraine's total area land equivalent to
the size of Portugal in his speech
President Putin said the population of
the four regions with the Russian
citizens forever and while he made no
mention of nuclear weapons his
previously said nothing's off the table
when it comes to defending what in his
eyes is now Russian territory that's
raised fears of an escalation if
Ukrainian attacks in parts of the
Russian claimed regions continue
they'll try to ensure festive images on
television but people's real emotions
will be very far away from what's being
shown people understand that politics is
now on the battlefield on a whole
different level what's voted for and
what sign is not important in that sense
the Kremlin cannot offer anything
comforting to the Russians system uh
that wasn't it what the authorities did
of the public was this carefully managed
celebration the patriotism was clear
[Music]
appetite among ordinary Russians for a
prolonged conflict perhaps less so
by The Stroke of a pen President Putin
has redrawn the maps of both Russia and
Ukraine but now the difficult part
begins Ukraine and her powerful Western
allies insist the move should be
reversed Russia says it is going to
defend what it now calls its territories
by any means that implicitly includes
nuclear weapons Muhammad al-jazeera
Moscow